we talked about the Hall of Fame for a
couple of days now in particular Justin
Verlander it feels like there's been
this rubber stamp with Justin Verlander
is gonna be a Hall of Famer and I don't
think that he is at least not yet and
then Sports Illustrated's Jay Jaffe took
a deep dive into some of these players
who could be Hall of Famers our Hall of
Famers right now and Jay is kind enough
to join us on short notice let me start
with Verlander is Justin Verlander a
Hall of Famer right now Jay no but I
think you can say that you can look back
and say that about just about any 34
year old pitcher there aren't very many
who if they were to walk away today
would get these sort of Sandy Koufax
treatment and get in before reaching you
know some of the major milestones that
we typically associate with election to
the hall but Kershaw has a Hall of Famer
right now yeah of course I would say
Kershaw is yes because Kershaw it's got
those three sigh Young Awards there's
the only three syoma winner who's
outside the Hall is Roger Clemens and we
know why he's outside the Hall the most
important stat that you look at as a
pitcher by the way he's also the author
of Cooper's Cooperstown casebook we're
talking to Jay Jaffe so the the number
one stat you look for in a pitcher is
and the number one stat for a hitter is
what well I I tend to look at Wins Above
Replacement because I think that if you
want to examine baseball history in the
long view you need to adjust for all the
changes that have come down in over a
hundred years and in scoring levels and
ballparks and things like that
what Wins Above Replacement does is kind
of equalize for all of that so I I have
a system called jaha's the Jaffe Wins
Above Replacement score it's a way of
comparing candidates to those who are
already in the Hall of Fame it's a it's
kind of a first cut mechanism but you
want to you know take a closer look at
all the qualifications that a guy has so
to me wins and strikeouts they're
interesting and important but I think
that's my starting point as Wins Above
Replacement and for Verlander
he's got fifty six point six career war
the average Hall of Fame starter has
seventy three point nine so he's a ways
away I also look at a player's
seven-year peak his best seven seasons
he's got 43 and a half there the average
Hall of Fame starter has about 50 I'm
looking at some other names here by the
way I misspoke on Bert Blyleven the
Veterans Committee voted him in to the
Hall of Fame oh it's right the writers
voted I was already by 11 in 14 years
took 14 years there you go I screwed it
up even again mike mussina Hall of Famer
to me yes he's he's a lot higher in my
in my jaws ranking system around twenty
ninth all-time than Verlander was about
seventy third all right CC Sabathia Hall
of Famer right now nobody he's getting
closer I mean I think that my system
doesn't love him but I do think that if
he gets to 250 wins and 3,000 strikeouts
I think he's gonna get there
does does your ranking factor in
pitching for a marquee team like the
Yankees of the Dodgers or the Red Sox no
no there's a lot that jaws doesn't
factor in that you that I think is
absolutely important to incorporate you
want to think about postseason stuff
obviously Verlander did some things to
enhancers cause CCC has done some things
to enhance his cause the marquee effect
yeah there's maybe something there I
think you have to be careful though you
know a lot of that gets incorporated
into the postseason already you know if
you're on a team like the Yankees that's
a perennial contender you have a much
greater chance than if you're on let's
just say the Houston Astros historically
speaking Carlos Beltran Hall of Famer if
his career ranged oh yes I have I have
him as one of the top ten center
fielders of all time
tremendous collection both on
traditional stats and advanced stats the
2700 hits the the 435 homers 300 plus
stolen bases with the highest success
rate and the eighth best shot score
among center fielders I think he's a
slam dunk in my mind but I don't know
the voters see it that way yet did it
help that Vlad Guerrero got in does that
help Beltran and all I think what
Guerrero getting in will help he's uh
you know Vlad's kind of blat had a great
first year showing on the ballot seventy
one point seven percent I think he gets
in either this year or next Joe Mauer
your opinion on Joe Mauer being a Hall
of Famer surprised me
yeah you know Joe Bauer did so much in
his years as his catcher before being
forced off the position by his
concussion I mean the three batting
titles the the MVP award I have him as
seventh all-time among catchers and
that's just based on you know is his
time behind the plate is his fifth in
terms of peak score his best seven
seasons you know I think as a guy on a
small-market team and one who's you know
salary has been disproportionate to his
contribution since moving to first base
he catches a lot of flack but he did so
much one of the best offensive catchers
of all time and a pretty solid defender
before the injuries forced him off that
positions yeah three Gold Gloves three
batting titles is Buster Posey a Hall of
Famer I think he's headed there
absolutely you know you look at what
he's done with the MVP award the Rookie
of the Year or the batting title the the
critical role in three championships i I
think he's well on his way Chase Utley
Hall of Famer I think so I don't think
he's going to get there the big thing
when I've studied the Hall of Fame is
that nobody with less than 2,000 hits
has been elected less than 2,000 hits
since the expansion era began in 1960
has been elected he's an 1850 and it
doesn't look like he's going to close
the gap we've seen a lot of guys with
less than 2,000 fall short Bobby Grich
being a prime example of the type of
player that out Lee is you know Dick
Allen another one who's below 2000
Minnie Minoso it's just it seems to be a
hard and fast rule that I wish the
voters could overcome Pedroia
I think if he can if he can bounce back
from this current knee injury and boy
that's a big if that you know the more
you learn about the cartilage stuff I I
think he'll get there he's got the
championships the MVP the Rookie of the
Year award but he's got to stay healthy
and unfortunately second base is a very
demanding position for that and a lot of
guys tend to flame out Curt Schilling's
political views keeping him out of the
Hall of Fame I don't think it's I mean I
think they're certainly not helping and
they you know he took a big step back in
the voting this past year but I think
he's eventually going
to get there I think the problem a lot
of people still have is they're going
just by the winds turtle which is what
around 210 without the recognizing the
high strikeout rate the best strikeout
to walk ratio of the you know since the
pitching distance got moved to sixty
foot six inches the you know the fact
that he was the Bob Gibson of his
generation when it came to postseason
stuff you know I think he had top 50% of
the vote
just a year over just over a year ago
and you know which is traditionally a
strong indicator of future election so I
think he gets there eventually but he's
probably going to have to let the
political environment change before he
gets there well it feels like Clemens
and bonds have let the political
environment or the steroid environment
or younger older writers you know that
maybe that cloud is kind of passing
through or passing over these guys and
maybe clear skies here yeah I I don't
know if it's fully clear yet but yes
those two paths 50% I think that the
evolving electorate is probably going to
eventually elect them before the the
remaining five years on the ballot are
up you know so I see I see those guys
getting in down the road too Jay thanks
for joining us we appreciate always fun
to talk about this contributing writer
at Sports Illustrated the author of the
Cooperstown case book Thank You Jay all
right thanks so much Dan a pleasure
that's Jay jeffing for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]